si se puede gritaban los chicos en la
gradería de este estadio el asmada vine
Alí en adoja y se pudo porque Costa Rica
venció Un gol por cero a Japón Japón que
venía de esa histórico resultado dos
goles por uno ante Alemania sin embargo
hay que decirlo este fue un partido en
realidad bastante aburrido sobre todo
los primeros 45 minutos sin disparos a
portería y Los japoneses que habían
salido con muchísima energía pero que
fue cayendo como espuma a medida que iba
pasando el tiempo las cosas cambiaron en
el segundo tiempo hay que decirlo el
técnico japonés cambió y puso a sano
este jugador que le da peligrosidad le
da velocidad a Los japoneses Y eso se
notó de hecho llegaron con mucha más
peligrosidad a la portería de Keylor
Navas Aunque sin éxito y fue justamente
en un descuido de Los japoneses ya sobre
el minuto 81 en que fuller encontró la
portería japonesa y gonda trató de
estirarse Y de atajar esa pelota pero
fue imposible de esta manera pues Costa
Rica consigue esta Victoria importante
para continuar con vida en este mundial
en este grupo que todavía las cosas Pues
están un poquito a ver qué es lo que va
a suceder esta noche porque España va a
enfrentarse a Alemania y sobre todo pues
todo va a definirse en la última fecha
Esto será el próximo jueves